emilia fester sie ist
bundestagsabgeordnete der grünen und hat
auf ins gebirge eingeladen jetzt werden
sie denken das ist doch nett was soll
daran schlimm sein eigentlich ist es
auch eine wirklich schöne idee wenn frau
fester nicht bürger aus grenzen würde
sie schreibt auf instagram ihr habt
vielleicht schon in meinem posting
gesehen von gestern ich würde euch gerne
mit zu einer berlinfahrt nehmen wenn ihr
eine junge frau oder inter trans nicht
binäre person aus hamburg seit lade ich
euch herzlich ein man stelle sich jetzt
einmal vor ein mann ein
bundestagsabgeordneter würde zu einer
reise nur für männer und alte frauen
ausrufen also ehrlich gesagt das wäre zu
recht ein riesen desaster und ich finde
ausgrenzung sollte keine einbahnstraße
sein was fällt frau fester eigentlich
ein nur menschen einzuladen die keine
männer und keine älteren frauen sind